Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my attack on titan season 4 episode 8 video
assassin's bullet there's so much stuff happening
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to my
channel i'm doing videos for all the attack on
titan season 4 episodes be sure to subscribe to
get everything careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet because we'll be talking
about everything and i'll just number these as
we go along through moments and easter eggs just
starting with the title of the episode assassin's
bullet obviously a reference to gabi braun sniping
sasha with her gun is the survey core and the
rest of the ldn attack team were taking off in
the airship everyone press f in the chat to pay
respects to the best potato girl who ever lived
don't worry we'll talk about sasha because
her death will have waves that will affect
all the other characters for the next big arc
of the series so we're sort of transitioning
from the marley arc of the manga to the war for
paradis arc that is the final arc of the story
i know everyone's freaking out because there are
only 16 episodes listed on the wiki for attack on
titan right now but there's no way that they could
speedrun the rest of the story in the amount of
episodes that are listed on the wiki right now
so they'll probably be a season 4 part 2 like
a second core of episodes but the episode starts
right where episode 7 left off with reiner having
completely regenerated himself well maybe not
completely but regenerated himself into another
armored titan to join the fight not because he
was trying to save the rest of the marleyans as
gabi and falco thought screaming their lungs out
at him but because he was still kind of hoping
for the chance just a small chance that if he were
to fight Eren yeager again Eren might kill him and
end his suffering and that would free him of his
guilty conscience over everything that he'd done
while he was on paradis all the people that they
killed all their friends that were hurt when they
took down the first ball then everything that came
after and this has a lot to do with what was going
on with reiner's titan because i've seen a lot
of people asking why his armor tightened and this
scene looks so different from its normal look the
armor plating doesn't cover his entire body his
face looks more like a normal face without the
standard plating covering it so it's like he's
entering battle with half of his armor on when you
think about the line of dialogue that he went out
on during episode 7 that should give you a clue as
to why he looks like this he purposefully stopped
his titan transformation before it completely
covered him in arbor plating because he wanted to
leave himself exposed he wanted to give Eren more
of a chance at killing him in battle in fact he's
not even trying here Eren pretty much one-shots
him even though he's able to grab porko's jaw
titan from him but i love that Eren is still a
post nutcracker incident with porko's jaw titan
and it hasn't had time to regenerate its limbs
so he's swinging it around like some kind of
titan club like he's carrying it into battle
while he's fighting there's some more creative
use of titans for you and even though he's just
drank that warhammer titan milkshake he's gained
the full power of that titan so he does learn new
titan powers pretty quickly but it's still going
to take him a hot minute to learn how to fully
integrate the warhammer titan abilities into
his other abilities as the attack titan and the
founding titan more to that too reiner showing up
stopped him short before he could take the power
of the jaw titan so right now as it stands after
the battle porco is still the jaw titan but after
he grabs the jaw titan and Eren one shots him Eren
stops short in his tracks claiming that he doesn't
have the energy to finish reiner off they kind of
referenced this earlier so it's possible that
he's being truthful but there's no malice on
his face when he's talking about it to mikasa so
it's possible here that he also chose not to push
himself to finish off reiner because he didn't
want to kill him like he told him in episode five
he doesn't want to destroy him anymore so here
he's just using the energy limit as an excuse to
do that to walk away then as the survey corps
the eldians take off in the airship gabi just
hits fever pitch and rushes after them with her
rifle trying to take all of them down by herself
falco chases her down and obviously this is the
biggest part of the episode this big emotional arc
that they're on like they hype up the Eren versus
reiner fight so much in last week's episode
gabi and falco are like oh you're gonna get it now
the armor titan reiner is gonna kick your butt so
bad but the battle is over so quickly that they're
like wait what what just happened like Eren vs
reiner is the smallest part of the episode they
blow past it so quickly love the look on armin's
face as he greets Eren and mikasa returning to the
ship they share that exchange the two of them and
there's so much weight in the looks that they give
each other armin still horrified by everything he
just did in the bay destroying everything like he
went off like a nuclear bomb when he transformed
into the colossal titan and he's so conflicted by
everything that Eren had done to force their hand
all this death and the collateral damage but he
still really cares about Eren just like mikasa
does but then of course levi shows up and starts
throwing insults at vand you kind of snap back
to reality like oh yeah everyone is super pissed
at Eren not just the marlians but all the eldians
as well the show has kind of set him up as the
new big bad of the series the past few episodes
the big villain that everyone hates and everyone
that's calling him a villain technically is not
wrong everything that willie tiber said in his
final speech about Eren unleashing the rumbling
activating the thousands of colossal titans that
make up the walls of paradis and destroying the
world all that's not wrong Eren at least as far as
we know right now still plans to do that so it's
kind of like everyone everyone around the world
versus Eren at this point the enemy of humanity
but in this moment as they all sort of reunite he
still has a few friends and he's such a high value
weapon two paradis that they're kind of forced to
work with him if he were not the founding titan
though or even the attack titan they probably
would have just executed him on spot for what
he did and that's also why armin stops mikasa
from intervening when levi starts smacking Eren
around and they formally arrest him he's like no
this needs to happen Eren needs to answer for his
crimes even though nobody here is enjoying this
although it seems kind of like levi is enjoying
smacking him around a little bit the only person
that levi enjoys smacking around more than Eren is
zeke so we'll talk about that in a second too when
levi says Eren has some explaining to do i don't
really expect Eren to be very forthcoming beyond
what he already wrote in his letters that's pretty
much what he tells him like it's all in there in
the letters that i sent you i've already explained
myself very clearly even though we as the audience
didn't get to read any of those letters the
reaction on his face is amazing too like Eren
doesn't even register any kind of reaction or
visible emotion because he's so committed to
his course of action in the rumbling then as the
rest of their forces start to board the airship
they start celebrating sasha talks about the six
soldiers they lost they start going on about how
they're going to rebuild the ldn empire after the
great titan war take back everything that was
taken from them which also kind of foreshadows
the big twist anytime they're celebrating before
they've actually left the battlefield you know
something big is happening there's going to
be some twist that'll take it back but then
she cuts the tension talking about more food this
is obviously just setting up the big twist in her
final words talking about food talking about meat
then we go back to gabi and falco and obviously
she's not having any of what falco is trying to
sell her on she remembers sophia getting crushed
during Eren's attack then udo getting trampled to
death by the panicking crowd while he was trying
to save her the marlian guards that then also
tried to save her and were killed by a woman on
the rooftop that woman was sasha obviously also
setting up the big twist with her killing sasha
in a little bit they also still think that zeke
is dead at this point in the story so they're
completely demoralized so all this anger that
she's feeling over the deaths of her friends
and her sympathy with the marlians now renewed
sympathy because the soldiers tried to save her
is coalescing into this perfect storm turning her
into a marly stan even though her whole life she's
been fed all this rhetoric and lies about the
eldians by the marlians she's on the fast train
to crazytown she wants to wipe all the eldians
off the map but she kind of explains where she's
coming from and she was not there for any of the
Eren reiner conversations that falco saw so falco
is kind of doing the slow work in the next arc of
the series trying to get her to come around on the
whole notion of war and killing her own people
because she's an eldian just like them as falco
was explaining this to gabi you kind of have to
laugh at her reaction to this she kind of calls
fake news on him like were you there for that
did you see that happen no i didn't see it happen
so her brain has gone so crazy town that she's
kind of pretending like it's not a thing like i
i don't think that that's a thing i don't think
that they killed all those people when clearly
that all happened like we all saw it play out over
the first couple seasons of the show she's able to
hit one of their soldiers but because he's still
attached to the 3d maneuvering cable anchored to
the airship she uses it to go full leeroy jenkins
on the entire airship falco unsuccessfully trying
to stop her winding up going along for the ride
just remembering reiner's last conversation with
him you need to save gabi but gaby and falcao
are able to get on the ship getting a shot off
on sasha before everyone realizes what's happening
and she doesn't die immediately but she does go
out on such a great line asking where her dinner
is in her actual last word being meat obviously
big call back to her on the wall as Eren remembers
her at the end of the episode laughing and crying
at the same time the whole weight of sasha's death
is going to hang over the next arc of the series
in a really important way so her death will inform
some really important actions from her friends and
these other characters that are all tied up in
this gabi and falco's arc in particular it's just
that it's going to take gabi a long long time to
get to that place mentally but it kind of starts
when you see the other eldian soldiers show them
mercy like do we want to throw them right out the
hatch and just dash their bodies on the rocks
no when does the killing stop they hate all
this as much as falco remembers reiner hating it
so falco's sort of realizing this connecting all
the dots in his head like wait a minute they're
just like us but back on marley we see pieck
healing up none the worse for wear and magath
trying to pick up the pieces tracking down all
the other titan warriors like reiner pique starts
recalling the strange marlian soldier that tricked
them into the pit earlier that's yelena she's
one of zeke's confederates inside the marleyan
army you learn a little bit about her during this
episode but they'll continue to reveal more about
her in the next couple of episodes it's not so
much that she loves paradis and she wants to see
them burn marley to the ground or anything like
that she's just a zeke stan through and through
as we'll continue to see her character is a good
example a good template for the idea of zealotry
like who are the good guys in all this when the
supposed forces of the protagonists Eren and the
other eldians are doing things that are just as
horrific and underhanded as what the marlians have
been doing this whole time it's another example
of what they've been trying to convey through
this entire marley arc of the series that everyone
is the same there are no winners in this war only
losers and both sides are to blame both sides are
just as bad as the other except for Eren yeager
he's kind of like the s-tier bad guy at the moment
right now then i love this gabi and falco reversal
as they reveal what was going on with zeke the
whole time she's screaming about making them
pay for killing zeke and they're like hold that
thought you can tell him all about it yourself
when we show you and you open the door and they
see him sitting there regenerating his limbs
hanji steps out talking to zeke about the whole
plan how it all went down revealing to gabi and
falco that zeke was in on this the whole time he
was behind this big attack the miscalculations
that zeke is talking about obviously are gabi and
falco winding up on board that was not planned as
well as pieck and porco escaping the trap and were
able to intervene during the battle resulting in
more paradis casualties and levi's conversation
with zeke should make it pretty clear where they
stand with each other levi still very much wants
to kill him but is forced to work with him for the
greater cause of defeating the marlians in the
moment and zeke doesn't really care about levi
at all he's just using him to achieve his plan of
wielding the power of the founding titan through
Eren he really only cares about Eren and the
founding titan because they're so critical to his
plan the paradis eldians are really just a means
to an end for him he doesn't really care about
them either like he talks about freeing eldians
all over the world and he does kind of want to
do that but he has zero remorse over the idea that
so many people are gonna have to die before this
plan comes to fruition then Eren reminds us the
whole reason for the surprise attack destroying
the fleet their command structure just to delay
the inevitable all-out war for paradis that's the
title of the final arc of the manga story the war
for paradis that's where we're heading into right
now so it's coming obviously it's just that it's
going to take maga time to rebuild their ships
so that they can actually bring the marlians to
paradis to have the war itself i love the little
joke that hanji gets out about referencing saving
Eren all the time there's always somebody that has
to come save you which isn't wrong usually it's
mikasa that always winds up having to save him
it's just that this time in particular it was
extra crazy because of the circumstances Eren
forcing their hand into battle purposefully making
himself a hostage then just as zeke is trying
to remind them that this is not all in vain they
reveal sasha has died everyone has their own level
of reaction based on how close they were to sasha
but they're all pissed and even Eren like i said
is saddened by it he starts crying and getting
really broken up about it remembering that her
final word was meat thinking back about the time
she stole the meat from the officer's mess trying
to share it with all them so even though he seemed
like a monster during this past arc it shows that
he's not a total psychopath just a little bit of
a psychopath but the voice you hear speaking over
the trailer for episode 9 is yell in his voice
talking about how they may have been able to find
some other way of achieving their goals without
all the bloodshed but what's done is done there's
nothing we can do about it we see the flashback of
sasha eating seafood for the first time cooked by
one of the marleyan soldiers freaking out because
she loves it so much then them burying her body
in hanji making more plans so my episode 9
video will post next sunday just like normal
but if you spotted any more big references
or easter eggs during episode 8 that i didn't
mention in the video just write them below in the
comments everyone click here for all my attack on
titan season 4 episodes and click here for that
brand new Wandavision episode 5 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and think about sasha when you eat dinner tonight!